ده رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شر ميشال الى
ممارسه مزيد من الضغوط على روسيا بسبب
حربها في اوكرانيا
قمه العشرين انه ينبغي استغلاله جميع
اجتماعات القمه والاتصالات غير الرسميه
التي تصاحبها من اجل اقناع يقول الاطراف
بممارسه مزيد من الضغوط على روسيا انطلاقا
من ان شرعه الامم المتحده ومبادئ السياده
تقول انه لا يجوز تغيير حدود الدول بالقوه
وانه على كل شركاء مجموعه العشرين احتراما
شرعه الامم المتحده
كنا استمعنا قبل قليل وزير الخارجيه
سرجيله
صحفيين لكن ماذا عن تعطيه وتعامله مع هذه
الكلمات المشاركين في القمه التي توجه
الانتقاد لروسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا
اعطى نوع من
وازال نوعا من الضبابيه فيما يتعلق
بالبيان حيث كان هناك رجال كبير حول همم
صيغه نهائيه للبيان ولكن من الواضح بحسب
الوزير الروسي سيكون هناك بيان فعليا تم
الانتهاء من صياغته سيلبي همم تقييمات همم
الروسيه همم الغربيه فيما يتعلق باشان
الاوكرانيا حسب ظروف قال ان ال- همم
البيان سي يتضمن تم تحديدا غربيه همم حرب
الروسيه على اوكرا يتضمن ايضا الموقف
الروسي الذي يعبر عن وجهه نظر اخرى على حد
تعبيريه وقال ان روسيا لا تريد على ان
كانت السبب في عدم الخروج ببيان سيما وانا
قمه العشرين هي قمه اقتصاديه
تاج برايه الى تكافل الجهود من اجل الخروج
من الازمات التي تعصف بالعالم وليست
مرتبطه همم كما كما يرى بالازمه
الاوكرانيه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه ان
ثانيه كان هناك همم تركيزها من قبل
الوزيره الروسي مريم على مساله امكانيه
تمديد همم اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب ويبدو من
لقائه بالامين العام للامم المتحده هناك
اشارات ايجابيه همم الوزير الروسي قال لي
مبروك خلال القائمهما انه حصل على ضمانات
مكتوبه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن
الاتحاد الاوروبي همم المتعلقه برفع
العقوبات على روسيا في ما يتعلق بتصدير
الحبوب والاغذيه والاسمده كما نعلم اتفاق
مبادره البحر الاسود يشمل الاتفاقين اتفاق
بين اوكرانيا والامم المتحده واتفاق بين
روسيا والامم المتحده تصدير الحبوب
الاوكراني والتصدير ايضا المواد الغذائيه
اسمي ده روسيه هذه هذه الاتفاق الذي براء
روسيا لم تلتزم مع الدول الغربيه لحد الان
همم بشروطه والتي اا هذا الاتفاق الذي
تراه الامم المتحده كما نعلم من همم اليوم
سيغادر طبعا على الوزير الروسي البيان
سيصدر غدا كانت هناك لقاءات ثانويه كثيره
لقاء بين الرئيس بين الامريكي والتركي كان
هناك لقاء قصير بين وزير الاوقاف
والمستشاره الالماني والله في شوز وايضا
بين الرئيس الفرنسي همم مانويل ماكرون
الذي اكد بحسب الوزير الروسي علامه سيستمر
في الاتصالات قريبا مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين من اجل ندفع عمليه التسويه
همم السياسيه همم وحل الازمه في اوكرانيا
هذا هي الازمه التي
حرب لاول مره يعترف بان حرب ولكن وصفها
بحرب هجينه بداتها همم بداتها واشنطن
بدرجه الاولى منذ دعامات ما وصفها
بالانقلاب عام 2010 نعم نعم
انا من بالي